[Musique]
bonjour la réunion bonjour le monde
entier s'y atteler bien non les mieux
comment il est alors bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro d'on n'est pas sorti de
l'auberge
bonne année 2010 8 à 7 ça c'est évident
alors pour commencer aux seynois partie
devine la noue les à la plaine des
palmistes qui fait beau il fait chaud on
est chez elian et il y en a 10 à 20 du
ca prépare ainsi à cochons bringel 10
miles et l'ice après pas manger là dont
il devient tout de suite vient tout de
suite bien bien bon je me suis dit
bonjour merci d'accueillir nous
bienvenue chez moi c'est joli où ça nous
mènera la paix' plein à petit plein sur
un plateau à 1200 mettre à niveau son
altitude d'accord explique comment
pourquoi
aujourd'hui partout la fuite on dirait
et n'a rien qu'en plaine des palmistes à
pluton pas bien et normal grand matin
mal à lever ma part activement ferment
le robinet celi ferme les robinets de la
pluie les enfants écoutent déjà les
justes carrément jolie cheyrou et ben
dis moi comme ça fonctionne
karrie webb du cari créole pas de
cauchemars que des trois branches de la
libye tenue la livre les effets
commencent à les manger il ya djallit
nom n'a d'autre chose pouvoir
bon on y va
[Musique]
quand tu fais pas allez viens je suis
n'est pas pauvre petit bonhomme
ohlala
[Musique]
tu as fait combien de monde
on se bat normalement bien qu'avec deux
de couple et mais suppose que wacken
pack de réunionnais ah oui c'est 50%
cliente à l'étranger et 50 pour cent
réunionnais d'accord à l'infini trouvant
à l'intérieur comment ça se passe il
fait combien de temps le le maison lassé
d envoi de la construire
ça fait quatre ans avec quatre ans mis
d'accord d'accord donc ça c'est le
nouvel arrivant loin le nouvel arrivant
d'accord d'accord alors par là bas mon
sommes un petit peu c'est quoi donc
ici c'est la salle 2 d'accord tout ce
qu'il faut pratiquer pour venir
tranquillement apprécié dans les haubans
en gros c'est vraiment agréable sur
super soleil je dis bon alex l'évier
jolie par la plantation cela mais il
faut aller fait que manger parce que
sinon on les abat manger il a lui cédé
lui c'est quelqu'un qui sait lui parler
thucydide mobile
ohlala
[Musique]
je suppose que c'est ouais selon madame
c'est mon épouse la bourde l'amour et
doux c'est beau c'est beau c'est qu'ils
avaient fait que manger et de cela tout
seul je crois pas alors diamant à faire
là me voilà dans l'unité la zone you
were 6 me wanna do nous c'est bien car
on peut parler oui mais les siens pis
alors donc appel à moi commence à faire
nous ça fait ça fait mais ça file en
europe
un petit car il n'a pas de cochon et
boit neil lennon du cari la réunion
balle en main propre aux achats leavitt
vais vous faire mousser résistance web
lé bon attaque démentie peu pour moi
c'est quoi pour les free mondiale pour
réussir un bon camarade cochon ben c'est
le temps de cuisson et comment la le feu
sous la marmite
c'est une faute non c'est une époque où
beaucoup préparé les amarres au bal mans
l'ailier nalaga n'est parfois l'anonymat
le gros sel aillent ensuite le giro le
poivre toi poivre en grains s'il vous
plaît monture avant maintenant que les
épices les déjà fait comme ça ben nous
ça va aller me le fais c'est le marmite
une ça commence m le bénéfice de barbie
alors là la patte cochon et une roue cyr
il roussi combien de temps à le dire
quinze minutes après 15 minutes c'est
forcément pas attendre nous à dakwa et
l'a donc une fois que les bien chaud là
non en un le sahara ajoute les épices
commence d'abord par les oignons
ça c'est une tradition il rajoute
toulouse où on va comme ça les gars ou
pluie et le vent
ben il paraît que le laïc plus vite aux
oignons deux arrêts et après ils brûlent
et revivre août et après l'accouchement
par année ou valley deux minutes le
temps les oignons ici est un peu quoi
donc là le live les tubes bouquet garni
d'accord donc là au rajout de les
safrans cuma plutôt le calme à quelques
miles
ouais ça en plus que ça c'est que tu
m'as que tu m'as mais c'est ça donne
vraiment la couleur quoi mais suppose
que monsieur pasqua
passons à la la plupart de produits si
ce n'est tout c'est qu'on a du produit
local voire sait plus qui conduit aux
cadres
[Musique]
l'indicé est là tu laisses quand ils
brûlent minutes après les joutes de
l'eau après la rajoute en rajoute de
l'eau dès l'instant pas tout de suite
quand j'entends des places dans les
épices qui imprègne de l'avion d'accord
et on va laisser tout ça mais je t'ai
une heure et demie après ses seins pour
thème le le temps le temps que tout cela
ait réduit sa visite le reste de mon nom
ma structure ou tout simplement
tout simplement parce qu'on a les
agrumes on a les agrumes et les pics de
le pic des sables c'est du collectif
[Musique]
allez une saint-just le dortoir c'est
une capacité de 14 places
c'est une grande chance de 10 et une
petite champs de qat lieu le 3 lits et
après on a une grande salle de bain pour
en fin de compte ça sert plus à des gens
qui ont du canyon et de la randonnée
oui voila je viens
je viens en effet de deux bons mais ça
va le matin faisant d'activités nature
pleine nature
on dirait qu'ils sont le dr al adl oua
remontée ben ouais mais là non finis
visite le ti structure ben alors on
passe à table vous menez j'adore ces
mots la table c'est presque plus joli
qu'un jeu thème des fusions
bonjour bonjour bana du monde comme ado
et ben ouais ben elle est à double
tranchant données entre des mondes
d'accord bonjour tout le monde
seiko nicolas préparer pose est
[Musique]
on prépare aux autres la fim biscuits
mes enfants regardent les marques aux
[Musique]
haricots avec citrouille de nos foires
avec 6 38 je pense qu'on va mettre tous
à table c'est moi qui faisais ce qu'il y
avait ce jeune fille a raison
alors là pas de cochon carry poulet le
chien qui aboyait autant qu il n'a pas
changé les toujours pareil pour un
grande histoire créole ça sent bon
ça m'a l'air d'être un truc
[Musique]
discuter pour tout dire
et comme il faut pas laisser tout seul
comme ça un plat on va bouter le
deuxième aussi la place joffre tous les
candidats cinq minutes y est bien allé
déjà bien manger bien d'accord bon
appétit à tout
[Musique]
m
la bon ben c'est ce qu'on appelle là tu
es vieux de faim ouais diamant un petit
peu comment où la houle a commencé le
pourquoi
coué l'orienta ouvert vers ce métier est
d'installer ou pour le coup à la plaine
des palmistes nana 20 ans ça me
travaille le bois de la ferme est
d'accord et salace et une maison de
vacances midi comme ça avant mais qui
fait de la randonnée faisait partie des
premiers réunionnais fête du camion et
la réunion et du pourquoi pas faire un
gîte dans un site aussi formidable et à
la petite plaine corps s'éclairent plein
plaine des palmistes et ça fait que
navin depuis vingt ans mais accueille
les camionneurs aussi bien espagnol
targuer de front aux ces allemands peut
tout moun et dernièrement à 80 voire mal
à refaire notre peau douce et les chants
date n'est pas parce qu'il ya une
clientèle qui demande d'un et ça fait
que ben a pris c'est super métier il
faut aimer parce que là dolan dont le
métier retail vous fait tout là-haut
fait jardiniers cuisiniers à
l'administratif the et après là dans la
ville
il faut pas avoir peur il faut lancer
toute façon on peut tomber noir sur la
tombe et wap encourage roulettes va pas
chape loin vers atr oui parce que ça
vous fait de bouts de relève merci
beaucoup même venu voir comment
structure comment il est ben écoute moi
mais ça allait pas médias ou revoir au
revoir notre offre mais si on a la
prochaine
ils meurent unis ok merci et bon à plus
tard à plus tard on reçoit autant ils
changent pour toujours
et oui messieurs dames c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on n'est pas sorti de
l'auberge
massa sera la semaine prochaine mais ne
pleurez pas je vais revenir promis juré
donc moins mon ventre les pleins that i
koné comment il faut faire un bon car il
a pas de cochon et bringel un donc plus
+ 2 plus de prétexte pour dire je sais
pas fait alors d'accord moi je
redescends des débats on n'est vraiment
pas sorti de l'auberge des médias note
ne pas sorti de l'auberge et momies
s'attend de mon bus ou mattson terrain à
la non mais il ya personne pathé dia
l'arrêt mais à peu près sont déjà ton
jeu allez
[Musique]